[MUSIC PLAYING]
CRAIG: Welcome to
Talks at Google.
I'm very pleased
to offer discussion
on the book "Meltdown."
Has any complex system that
you work with ever failed?
This discussion today by Chris
Clearfield and Andras Tilcsik
will tell you a little bit about
why these complex systems fail.
And they're going to offer some
suggestions on how to fix it.
I'd like to welcome our authors.
Chris is a former
derivatives trader,
licensed commercial
pilot, and he tells me
he's also a science geek.
And Andras has the
Canada Research Chair
in Strategy,
Organizations, and Society
at the University of Toronto's
Rotman School of Management.
They've written a great book.
I've read it, and
I hope you do, too.
Welcome, Chris and Andras.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS CLEARFIELD:
Thanks very much, Craig.
So before we dive
into the book, we
like to talk a little bit
about how we got interested
in this topic.
But also, wanted
to thank you all.
Although, probably not
everyone here works
in the Google Apps suite.
This book would not be written
if it were not for Google Docs.
So you can pass that
on to your colleagues.
Andras is in Toronto.
I'm in Seattle.
And we had many, many a Google
Hangout with the Google Doc
open where we were
kind of pounding away.
So thank you for that because
we wouldn't be here otherwise.
So as Craig said, this
book is about failure.
And it's about how failure
happens in complex systems.
And we just wanted
to talk a little bit
about how we got onto
this topic and how
we started thinking about it.
And then, go through--
kind of just skim
the surface of what
a little bit of
our research is, so
that we can have a
conversation about it.
Because I think you
guys more than many,
many organizations really think
carefully about this stuff
and are already working
with complex systems.
And many times, working with
them in a really effective way.
So our hope is that this is--
what we're contributing
is a perspective.
And that we can use that
to start a conversation.
So Andras and I got
into this research kind
of from different areas.
As Craig said, I was
a derivatives trader.
I traded during the
financial crisis.
And so I saw different
organizations
that managed that
process very well
and some that managed it very
poorly and went bankrupt.
And a lot of people saw
the impacts of that.
And so at the same time,
I was learning how to fly.
I was starting the process
of becoming a pilot,
and really interested
in the lessons
that aviation kind
of had learned
about how to manage these
complex and interconnected
systems.
And Andras in the meantime, was
finishing his PhD in sociology,
and looking at how
organizations made decisions.
And it was really after the
BP Deepwater Horizon oil spill
that we kind of came
together and started
thinking about this a little
bit more systematically.
And just started to try
to identify kind of two--
answer two big questions.
Which is 1, why are
these kind of failures
happening more and more?
And 2, what are capable
organizations doing about it?
And kind of, what can
we learn from that?
So when we're talking
about big failures,
today we're going
to start in what
seems like an unlikely place,
which is the festive holiday
season.
So this example, it's one of our
favorite examples in the book.
It's a social media campaign
that Starbucks was running.
They had this hashtag,
#spreadthecheer, right?
And I mean, it seems
so warm and fuzzy.
They wanted tweets
kind of like this,
"I love Starbucks gingerbread
lattes #spreadthecheer."
And as part of
this campaign, they
had sponsored a big projection
screen at an ice skating
rink in a museum in London.
And so the idea was they would
have this #spreadthecheer.
And then, those tweets would
come up on this screen.
Yeah, you guys see
where this is going.
People would enjoy it.
And listen, Starbucks is a
sophisticated company, right?
I mean, they think very, very
much about their marketing.
And they had a content
filter for these tweets,
but the content filter broke.
And so early on, you started
getting stuff like this,
"I like buying coffee that
tastes nice from a shop that
pays its tax.
So I avoid @starbucks
#spreadthecheer."
And Starbucks was enmeshed in
this kind of tax controversy
in the UK at the time.
Sorry.
Then, you saw, #spreadthecheer,
pay your tax bills, parasites."
And then, a couple
of people that
were a little less
subtle in their critique.
And what happened
was that people
started tweeting about the
fact that this was happening.
And then, we saw this
kind of snowball, right?
So we saw this avalanche effect
that we see in social media
where tweet after tweet after
tweet started happening.
And what's interesting is even
after they fixed the moderation
filter, I mean, the cat
was out of the bag, right?
The problem was
already happening.
And you know, Twitter
was abuzz with this.
It also jumped to the
traditional media.
Papers covered it.
So it was a PR meltdown.
And nobody died in it,
but it's a really kind
of interesting
place for our story
to start because this kind of
meltdown is not unique anymore.
We have the story of Knight
Capital, a pretty well-known,
at least in Wall
Street circles, trader,
who because of a-- basically,
because of a DevOps error,
they accidentally didn't
roll out a piece of software
on one of their eight servers.
They lost $500 million
in half an hour.
And that's a lot,
even for Wall Street.
A lot of us have
had this experience
where we've seen or read about
or even been in a situation
where flights are delayed.
Not because there's a problem
with the planes or the pilots,
but because there's a problem
with the airline reservation
system.
There's been a fire in
a data center somewhere.
Or in this case,
somebody accidentally
pulled the power cord out at
BA, and then the whole network
goes down.
I'm from Seattle.
In Washington state, there
was this amazing example
where in the state's
prisoner management system,
the Department of Corrections
was releasing thousands
of felons early for
a decade because they
had a bug in their code
that miscalculated sentences
and they didn't know about it.
And even after they
were told about it,
it took them three
years to fix it.
We all saw this happen in
Hawaii, where a pretty bad user
interface meant that this alert
that a ballistic missile was
inbound happened.
And then beyond that, they
hadn't designed for failure,
right?
So they couldn't pull
back the message.
They didn't have the
infrastructure to do that.
And so what all these things
have in common on the surface
is that they are all examples
of small problems snowballing
into these really big failures.
And that's what we see
over and over again.
And that's kind of
one of the things
that unifies these
sorts of failures
that we looked at in the book.
And when we dug past the
headlines, what we found
was that there's actually some
pretty compelling research that
describes kind of not
the precise failures that
are going to happen.
But in general,
the dynamics that
lead to these kinds of failures.
So these kind of
failures are more
likely to happen in
systems that are complex
and tightly coupled.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about what those mean.
But when a system is
complex and tightly coupled,
it's in what we think
of as the danger zone.
It's in this area where
these failures are
more likely to happen.
And when they happen, they
are more likely to spiral out
of control.
So from our definition
of complexity,
complexity means that
the system is connected.
There's a lot of connectivity.
It looks a lot like a web.
And it's hard to understand
what's going on inside it.
So if you think about that could
be because of computer code
or it could be
because it's something
like Deepwater Horizon, where
the action, if you will,
is happening miles under the
surface of the ocean miles
under the surface of the earth.
And tight coupling is this idea
that once the failure starts
to happen, there's
not a lot of slack
in our system to correct it.
So it moves faster
than we can move.
And we can't kind of put the
genie back in the bottle.
Once the error starts happening,
it's hard to recover from.
And when we have a system that's
complex and tightly coupled,
we tend to be in
the danger zone.
Now, this is research that
some of you might recognize.
It was done by a guy called
[? Chick Perot ?] in the 1980s.
And [? Chick Perot's ?]
research really
stemmed out of the Three
Mile Island nuclear meltdown.
And what he saw when he
did this research initially
is that there really
weren't that many systems
in this danger zone.
It was kind of
like nuclear power
and like big kind of
space/aerospace systems.
But what we have seen in
the research for our book
is that so many more systems
are in this danger zone today.
Whether we're talking
about finance,
or health care, or
transportation, or even
the kind of gadgets that
we bring into our lives.
Whether we're talking
about our homes
or internet-connected cars.
And so that's kind of the setup.
And that's sort of the bad news.
But the book is actually
deeply optimistic.
And we're going to have
time to talk about a couple
of solutions today.
And then, kick off
a conversation.
So Andras is going to start
with our first solution.
ANDRAS TILCSIK:
Yeah, thanks, Chris.
And as Chris said,
we don't have time
to go into all the solutions
we discussed in this book,
but we do have time to
give you a few tidbits.
So let me start with this thing.
These sentences were written
on a blog by a [INAUDIBLE]
gentleman about five
or six years ago.
He says, "She's unbelievably
beautiful to look at.
She stands extremely tall.
She's the most beautiful."
You look at these, you
think he's probably
writing about a
supermodel who is also
very tall and very pretty.
But it turns out he's actually
writing about an airplane.
And he's a KLM pilot, and he
really loves the Airbus 330.
If you read the whole
blog post, there
are like these 10
points in there.
It almost reads like a
love letter to the plane.
And what he loves
about it the most
is that it has this very sleek,
elegant, streamlined design,
both on the outside and on
the inside in the cockpit.
If you look at the
cockpit design here,
one of the things that
this pilot loved the most
is these small, little
side-stick controllers.
They are like little
joysticks that the pilots
used to control the plane.
And he loves them because
they are small, elegant.
They are out of the way.
They even leave space
for a tray table.
It's a French plane, so
lunch is very important.
The pilots get to pull it out.
They have their lunch.
It's very neat.
It doesn't obscure
the instrument panel.
It's set aside.
And they are also both
fully computerized.
So it looks like great design.
And if you compare that to
the design of a Boeing 737.
Similar plane in
many other ways,
but the setup of the
controls is very different.
Here, instead of the
elegant, little controls,
we have these big
W-shaped control yokes.
They stand on these
control columns
that are about 3 feet tall.
In fact, these things are so
big and bulky that the seats
of the pilots need to
be cut out in the front.
They are sort of split over
here to make space for them.
And these things are
not fully computerized.
In fact, the two controls
are mechanically physically
connected.
So if I pull mine
back, it's also
going to go back
on Chris's side.
And in fact, if I pull
back too hard and too fast,
it probably hits him in the knee
and makes him spill his lunch
on his shirt, which
is actually something
that pilots complain
about all the time.
So if you look at
this, it's big.
It's bulky.
It's oversized.
And it makes you spill
your lunch on your shirt.
It looks like terrible design.
But it turns out that there's
something really helpful
and something really beautiful
about these ugly designs.
Or at least this
particular ugly design.
And it's that it makes
everything the other pilot does
immediately visible.
It's literally in your face.
So if I'm pulling back
or pushing forward,
it's very easy for Chris
to see what's happening
and what I'm doing.
And in fact, with the
side-stick controls,
we've already seen a
number of accidents--
two or three in just
the past few years--
where one of the pilots on
one of those Airbus planes got
confused in the
heat of the moment.
They were trying
to manage a crisis.
Instead of pushing
forward to avoid a stall,
they were pulling
back on the control.
And the other pilot, the
more experienced pilot,
could have caught that error
and could have intervened,
but they just didn't see it
because the side-stick control
is to the side.
And that would never
happen with these giant,
ugly, bulky controls, which
are literally in your face
and probably hitting you
in the knee and the belly.
And we actually see
this sort of principle
over and over again in
our research for the book.
This idea that we
often privilege
elegance and love the
sleek and shiny designs.
But often, those designs also
make things less transparent.
And sometimes, that
kind of transparency
is really valuable.
And what we found is--
what's very
interesting is that we
see this principle not just in
the design of physical systems.
We see it with airplanes
and car design.
But we see it even in the design
of financial or accounting
systems.
Or to give you one more example
that's not technological.
People might remember
this from last year,
the Oscars mix up in 2017 when
the wrong film was announced.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: "La La Land."
ANDRAS TILCSIK: It's not
"La La Land," I'm sorry.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: "Moonlight."
ANDRAS TILCSIK: It's
"Moonlight," I am sorry.
Yes.
So part of that confusion
came from the design
of the envelope.
I mean, look at this.
It's pretty elegant.
It's this artful
red, gold lettering
that's supposed to
be the category name,
but we can't really read it.
And especially if you
are standing backstage,
it's really hard.
And if I grab the
wrong envelope,
it's very hard for anyone to see
that a mistake is being made.
And now, take a look at
what they did this year.
They learned, right?
I mean, this is not
a pretty design.
I mean, I am pretty
terrible at these things,
but this is the kind
of thing I would
design if they told me to.
It says "Best Picture"
with huge font.
And it says "Best Picture"
again in small font.
And it's not pretty.
It's ugly, but it's
very transparent.
You make it so
transparent that when
you're sitting at
home watching on TV,
you can probably tell
if there is a mistake.
And that's really the
same kind of principle
we see with the airplanes, where
the other pilot, the monitoring
pilot, can intervene.
And with that, I'll
turn it over to Chris,
who I think will talk
about another way
to get transparency.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah.
So I'm just talking
about transparency
through thinking about
how we design our systems.
But another big way
to get transparency
is by learning
about our systems.
And that's because in
particular, complex systems--
we can't sort of sit
down ahead of time
and write down all of the
ways that our systems are
going to fail.
We can't sit down ahead of
time and kind of just list ab
initio, these are the
things that can go wrong,
because we don't know.
These failures come
from these interactions.
But what we can do is we
can increase transparency
by learning from the
failures that do happen
and preventing them from kind
of spiraling out of control.
And so it turns out that
there's one big obstacle
to learning about our systems.
And that is actually its bosses.
Now, bosses.
As a boss, bosses see
themselves as somebody
who is very friendly.
They have an open door policy.
You know, they encourage
people to speak up.
But what the research shows is
that people that are managed,
they often see their
bosses more like this,
as these kind of sort of scary,
bear-like, shadowy creatures,
right?
And this is something I
think you guys probably
have a more
forward-thinking discussion
than a lot of companies.
Because you know,
Project Aristotle, one
of the big things
that came out of that
was how psychological safety
helps with performance.
And that's really what
we're talking about here.
We're not talking about it
in the performance context,
but we're talking
about it in the context
of getting information
about the things that
are going wrong kind of up and
distributed to decision makers
as broadly as possible.
And so there's a lot of
really interesting research
that goes into this.
We're going to talk about
of two threads of that.
So if you take a
look at these two--
this graph.
So this is a graph of two kind
of groups of different teams
solving a complex problem.
Everybody has different
pieces of information,
and they have to bring
that information together
to solve the problem.
So the blue team
and the red team.
Or sorry, the blue
group and the red group,
each of which is comprised
of different teams.
A number of them.
So if you look, the blue
group proposes five solutions.
The red group proposes
closer to seven.
The blue group shares about half
as many facts before a decision
is reached.
And that's really
interesting, right?
I mean, the solutions are
significantly different.
The number of solutions.
But the facts are
just wildly different.
So the red groups have a
much more thorough discussion
before a solution is reached.
And you might ask, well, why?
What's kind of behind this?
Is there something intrinsic
about these managers
of these groups as leaders?
Or kind of what is it?
Do they have MBAs?
Do they have kind of more
leadership experience?
And it turns out it's
nothing like that.
It turns out that
the intervention
is very, very small.
The leaders of the
blue groups are
taught to start their
discussions with this phrase--
the most important thing is that
we all agree on our decision.
Now, here's what I
think could be done.
The leaders of these red
groups, on the other hand,
of these red teams, are
taught to start by saying--
the most important thing is that
we air all possible viewpoints
to reach a good decision.
Now, what does each of
you think should be done?
That's pretty dramatic, right?
I mean, this very
small intervention
yields dramatically different
discussions and number
of solutions that are proposed.
Now, one critique of this
study is you might look at it
and say, well, this is
just a psych study, right?
So how does this actually
apply in the real world?
And I think actually, you guys--
again, through
Project Aristotle,
you guys actually have some
of the most exciting data
about how this can
apply in the real world.
But we also have a
really nice context
where we have a lot of good data
about how this kind of thing
applies.
And that comes actually
from commercial aviation.
So if you look at the accident
rate over the last four decades
in commercial aviation, it
has plummeted dramatically.
And that is despite the
increasing complexity
of the system and the kind of
increasing technology in it.
And commercial
aviation has come up
with a number of things,
a number of strategies
and lessons that make them
more effective at dealing
with this kind of big
system that they run.
But one of them is called
crew resource management.
And crew resource management
is, among other things,
kind of a script for
how flight crews can
talk about the decisions
that they need to make,
and how they can surface issues.
But also, how the captains
can listen to those issues
and encourage those
voices of concern.
And one of the things that
crew resource management does
is it's a script.
It's a script for how first
officers can share concerns
and how captains should
listen to those concerns.
And this isn't a lot
different than a kind
of boss-employee relationship.
There's a hierarchy
in the cockpit.
The captain is usually
more experienced
than the first officer.
But the first step for the
first officer to raise a concern
is to start by getting
the captain's attention.
So you might say, hey, Andras.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: I'm
the captain now?
CHRIS CLEARFIELD:
Andras is the captain.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: That's awesome.
All right.
Hey, Chris.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Hey, Andras.
I'm worried that we're going
to be late for our talk
at Google, because I've heard
that traffic in the Bay Area
is pretty notorious.
I'm going to state the problem.
I'm going to propose a solution.
I think we should leave
really early from our hotel,
so we make sure we
get there on time.
And then, we get
explicit agreement.
How does that sound to you?
ANDRAS TILCSIK: Sounds great.
I'd hate to miss that talk.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Right?
So what's fascinating about
this is not its sophistication,
because it's not.
I have a five-year-old.
This is how I talk with
my five-year-old about how
he can raise concerns,
how he can ask for help.
But what's really interesting
about this is this
had a dramatic effect
on the accident rates
in commercial aviation.
In particular, when the
captain was the pilot flying.
That's what's really
interesting about this.
So before, first officers
wouldn't challenge the captain.
It was more likely
that the captain
was the one flying during
these crew-caused mistakes.
After crew resource
management and this language
of dissent was kind of--
the language of dissent was
taught, but also learned
by the captain, by the bosses.
That changed dramatically.
And I think there's
a bigger lesson here
because we don't all
fly in airline cockpits.
But what it teaches us is
that speaking up and listening
are teachable skills.
And that's a really
powerful thing.
I think that's a really
powerful takeaway.
And what that
means is that there
are techniques that
we can use kind
of in our day-to-day
lives, in our organizations
to help encourage that.
And that turns out to be
one of the keys to learning
from our systems, and adding
transparency, and catching
those small errors before
they turn into the big ones.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: All right.
And I think we have time
to talk about one more
set of solutions.
And this is something
that really surprised us.
This really wasn't
in our book proposal.
This was not something
we thought about earlier,
but it's something
that we kept running
into as we were studying cases
of failure and resilience.
And let me introduce this
with an example as well.
Take a look at
these two students,
hypothetical students.
Let's call them Student
A and Student B.
And imagine that they
are both applying
to an elite,
academically-rigorous
university.
Which of them do you
think would be a stronger
candidate for admission?
If you asked people that
question individually,
something like 95% or 98% of
people will say it's Student A.
And it makes a lot
of sense, right?
Student A has a higher
GPA, better SAT scores,
and their activities don't seem
to be any inferior to those
of Student B, unless you think
that drama club is really
that important.
But it really seems like the
right answer is Student A.
But of course, this is when
we asked people the question
on an individual basis.
But as humans, we
are funny creatures
when we are in our
group in a social setup.
And one interesting
experiment that
was done actually
just a couple of years
ago by researchers at MIT and
a couple of other places, what
they did is they put
people in a room.
They gave them the
exact same problem
that I just gave you,
Student A versus Student B,
and a number of other problems.
And they setup the room so
that each room would only
have one actual subject.
The other three
people were actors
who were working
with the researcher.
And the researchers
instructed the actors
to give the wrong answer.
To say Student B when the
problem was presented.
So they would say Student
B, Student B, Student B.
And in a very large
number of cases--
and you might
recognize this setup
from the famous Asch
conformity experiments that
were done a few decades ago.
The actual subject would
also say Student B,
even though we know that when
we asked people individually,
a very small
percentage of people
would think that Student
B is the right answer.
And a vast majority would agree
that it's actually Student A.
Yet here, after hearing
these three strangers say
Student B, Student
B, Student B, we
are much more likely to
say it's Student B. Much
more likely to give
the wrong answer.
What's really interesting
about this though,
is what happens when you
rerun the same experiment
with diverse groups.
In this case,
racially-diverse groups.
So still the same setup.
We have three actors, the same
problem, one actual subject.
We introduce some ethnic or
racial diversity in this case,
but its setup is the same.
The actors say
Student B, Student B,
Student B. But in these
cases, the actual subject is
much less likely to fall victim
to this kind of conformity
and much more likely to give
the right answer, Student A.
And this is something we see
across a very large number
of studies done in the
past five or so years,
this effect that diversity
makes everyone more skeptical.
And that's a very
different way of thinking
about the facts or
benefits of diversity
than what we usually do.
Usually, we think diversity
doesn't really do anything.
Or if it does something,
it's because people bring
different ideas to the table.
It's this sort of beautiful
group process where
we each bring something
unique, and then we
learn from each other.
And there's this
great discussion
and it's this beautiful thing.
Well, what this research
shows is that in many cases,
diversity is much more
painful than beautiful.
It's almost like a
speed bump effect.
It makes things less
smooth, less pleasant.
It makes things harder,
but it wakes us up.
And we see this kind of
effect not just in the lab.
We see it in field
studies, lab studies,
across all kinds of domains,
and across types of diversity
as well.
Whether it's diversity
in surface-level things.
Things like race
and gender and age.
But also, in things like
professional background.
Things that are
not on the surface,
but they seem to trigger
the same kind of effect.
And we see this in finance.
We see it in juries.
We see it in a corporate
boardroom very,
very consistently.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: So
I'm going to bring
this home with kind of a summary
of what we've just looked at.
So we started by
talking about systems,
and how we can use design
to inject some transparency
into our systems.
But design isn't the only thing
that can help our systems.
There's a number
of other things.
One example that
we really like is
you can use this idea of
complexity and coupling,
and you can sort of use that
as a heuristic to figure out
which of your systems you
should be paying attention to,
where these kind of
failures are more likely.
We talked about learning.
Learning by hearing
voices of concern
from inside your organization.
But there's other ways of
learning about our systems,
too.
We can learn by obsessing about
small failures that happen.
And really, using them as tools
to increase our understanding
of how our system might fail.
And finally, we talked
about, broadly speaking,
decision-making.
We talked about
how diversity can
be a boon to how we can
make decisions in groups.
But there's other ways we can
improve our decision-making
too, from introducing
outsiders--
something that groups like
NASA's Jet Propulsion Labs
does--
to using kind of a set of
predetermined criteria to score
options that we have when
we're making a decision
between a couple of things.
And so I think broadly
speaking, the solutions
that we have researched fall
roughly into these categories.
But there's a lot of
nuance and there's a lot
of different texture to them.
And I mean, one thing that
you might be thinking--
and that we thought
a lot as we were
reading the book-- is that this
stuff isn't rocket science.
I mean, you don't
have to be a genius
to introduce an outsider into
your decision-making process.
And what we kind
of came down to was
that these solutions
are simple, but that
doesn't mean that they're easy.
And what we see
over and over again
is examples where instead of
going for transparent design,
we choose sort of
sleek, shiny design.
Instead of listening
to voices of concern,
we ignore them
and suppress them.
And you know, what
happened in Flint,
Michigan with the
lead poisoning crisis
is a great example of that.
Or rather, a tragic
example of that.
And even though we know
the value of diversity
and how it actually helps
groups make better decisions,
a shocking number
of groups making
some of our most
important decisions
are strikingly homogeneous.
And so really, what our
kind of broad thesis is,
is that the world has changed.
A lot more of these systems
are in this danger zone.
They're complex and
tightly coupled.
And they lead to these
kind of idiosyncratic.
And yet, somehow connected
shared sets of failures
caused by a shared
set of things.
And many of our
organizations, many
of our most important
organizations,
their decision-making, the way
they approach these things,
hasn't yet caught up.
And so our hope with this
book is to really just start
a conversation about that.
And so that's where
we'll end for today.
And rather, that's where
the conversation will begin.
So thank you for your
attention, and we'd
love to have a discussion
if anyone has any questions
or thoughts.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG: There's a
microphone over here.
If you have questions,
please step up to the mike.
And the authors have said
they'll take as many questions
as we have time for.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: I
have a flight at 6:00.
But until then, I'm good.
CRAIG: So please, step up.
Have your shot at them.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD:
Somebody has to be first.
AUDIENCE: I'll be first then.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: OK.
AUDIENCE: I've not had a chance
to read through the whole book
yet, but I wanted
to ask your opinion
of artificial intelligence.
Where does this
apply to the system
and the complexity
of the systems
that we're seeing today?
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So where does this apply
to artificial intelligence?
I mean, I think artificial
intelligence in many ways is--
I mean, I think
it's a big question,
so there's a lot of answers.
I mean, on the one hand,
artificial intelligence
is in some ways the
ultimate black box, right?
So it sort of takes transparency
and entirely removes it
and replaces it with
a set of parameters
that nobody but the
model itself understands.
And so I think from that
perspective, that I would say
is a little bit concerning.
Do you have anything to add?
ANDRAS TILCSIK: Yeah.
No, I would say that.
I think there's
potentially an upside, too,
in terms of these issues.
And I think that
this notion that AI,
if used correctly
and well-calibrated,
will allow us to
predict things in a more
effective way, especially in
these very complex systems.
So it's this interesting
tension between,
are these things going to be the
ultimate black box or are they
going to be our most effective
prediction machines that we
can use to prevent, or at least
foresee some of these failures?
Or at least learn better from
the enormous amounts of data
that we are generating
as we are trying to learn
about these small failures.
And I think at
Google, either way
I think the challenge is to
sort of manage that trade-off
and end up on the positive path.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: And
I think I would also
kind of push the
answer back a level
and say that, I
think whether or not
AI is able to help
or hurt depends
on the organizations that
are building the AI, too.
And whether or not they are able
to surface voices of concern
or pay attention to these
things that aren't quite right.
Because I think the other
side of the AI question
is that we're building AI
into more and more important
systems.
We can talk more
about this, but I
think driverless cars are
an excellent example of both
the upside and the
challenge of that.
Thanks.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So I was thinking
about the airplane example.
And you know, there's
this funny thing
that when you talk
to users, sometimes
they don't know what they want.
Or they think they know they
want, but really they're wrong.
And maybe this is
just UX design, which
I don't know anything about.
But I wonder if just as there
are techniques for encouraging
dissent in a
[INAUDIBLE],, are there
techniques for getting users
to be-- like the people who
designed the new cockpit style
must have talked to the pilots.
And I guess they must
have heard, oh, it's
a pain in the butt that we
knock each other's lunch
on their shirts.
And they weren't made
to think of the things
that they were really
using about that interface.
Are there techniques?
Just like for the
[INAUDIBLE],, are there
techniques of getting
users to better understand
what are the mechanisms that are
making their systems not work?
ANDRAS TILCSIK: I think
that's a great question.
And I think what we've
seen in the aviation
case is that it's not so much--
I think it's a huge
challenge to get people
to describe what they
want and how-- especially
in the cockpit design, where
it's really hard for a pilot
to describe how they
might be interacting
with this interface
in a crisis situation.
People can explain,
oh, on a normal day,
it will be very nice
to have my lunch.
And it's going to
be very comfortable.
But it's really hard to
kind of think through that.
And I don't think that's
what aviation has done.
So I think with--
well, maybe in the
Airbus case they
sort of talked to their pilots.
And maybe that's
part of the problem
rather than watching what
the pilots actually do.
The reason we are learning about
these issues, and the reason I
could show you
the slide and talk
about the benefits of that
ugly but transparent design
is that we are seeing accidents.
Or actually, some near misses
where we see people in action.
And of course, aviation
has a huge advantage
in that we have cockpit
recordings and black boxes.
And we know exactly
what was happening
and who was pulling back
and who was pushing forward.
But I think the broader
lesson there is to--
I mean, it's really
about the basic principle
of design thinking, of
watching people interact
with these systems across a
number of different situations
rather than necessarily
listening to them
as they are explaining it.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: I think
there's an element of it,
too, that Andras
kind of touched on,
which is not designing for
the blue sky day, right?
Sort of pushing yourself
and your design team
to look for all-- when you
go off the happy path, right?
And I think that
you could imagine
the Airbus is having
a design where
they have those
lovely side sticks,
but they are physically linked.
They are physically connected.
And for us, that's
kind of this--
I think what we see is that
the users can take you so far,
but then you also have to
think in terms of this--
in terms if you think about
transparency, complexity,
and coupling as variables when
you're designing the system,
then that can give you some
really powerful insights to how
to make sure that your
sphere of design is broader,
I guess I would say.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: Yeah.
We talked about this
idea of learning
from these small
failures as they happen.
I mean, one of the hallmarks
of a complex system
is that you can't sit
down and just predict
how things might fail, but
you can learn something
about how things might fail as
people are using the system.
So another example is the
design of gear shifters
in cars, where we
are actually seeing
the exact same kind of
process where there have been
a number of designs
in recent years
that are very
sleek, very elegant.
They are low dials
and things like that.
Things that are
mostly computerized,
don't have a lot of
physical feedback.
And car companies
introduced them
because they could and they
look nice and they were pretty,
but we started seeing
a number of accidents
where people didn't know
what gear their car was in.
They would get out of the car.
They would get injured or
the car would get damaged.
And there was data about that,
but the companies didn't really
pay attention to that.
And often, that kind
of data is much more
valuable than asking
a user, would you
like this little dial?
People are pretty
terrible at knowing
what they'll actually use.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD:
Other questions?
Could you use the microphone?
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So going back
to the Starbucks example,
it sounded like these
[INAUDIBLE] systems
and there's a lot of
human factor involved.
This is not something new
that the trolling is pretty
common on the Twitter world.
So looking back to your
framework, what [INAUDIBLE]
how could have Starbucks
done things differently?
I want to understand how
these principles apply?
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah.
Well, I would start
even a step back
where you're right that this
is not an unfamiliar dynamic
for-- trolling is not an
unfamiliar dynamic for Twitter.
But I think it's also easy
to forget how new Twitter is.
So if you think about
Starbucks and they're
kind of building up their
experience marketing.
Most of that experience
or a lot of it,
especially at the time
where this was done,
was built up in the
non-Twitter world, right?
It was built up in the--
we come up with a campaign, we
push it out to people, people
like it or don't like it.
As you said, this is
an example where they
have this kind of feedback.
What I think, I guess, is--
I mean, one thing might
be, be a little bit more
skeptical of how you
are engaging users.
Again, they designed for going
off the happy path a little bit
in that they had
this content filter.
But the fact that the
content filter broke.
I mean, I think on the face of
it means that they didn't put
the engineering talent or they
didn't take the process as
seriously as they could have,
as they maybe needed to.
And I think that is
actually a surprising--
that is actually something that
companies have to learn from.
That just like United
Airlines is seeing with--
I mean, they just had PR
disaster after PR disaster,
right?
It used to be that that would
stay on the plane, right?
And maybe other
customers on that
flight would be aghast that
somebody was pulled off
in that way.
But now, it goes global.
And it goes global immediately.
And I think that the way that
these controversies can spread
mean that these
companies have to take
a very different
approach to managing
not just their marketing,
but also their kind of--
their whole approach
to this kind of thing.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: I'll
add two other things.
One is while
researching the book,
we have come across a number of
these tools that teams can use.
Little exercises that
allow them to think
about these sort of
less expected risks
more effectively than
they normally do.
You'll see a number
of examples of that.
The other thing
I'll add is relating
to our point about diversity.
So the Starbucks controversy
around wages and taxes
at the time was really big and
really prominent in the UK.
But this was a global campaign.
And I think people
rolling out the campaign
might not have
been aware of just
how controversial
and problematic
this could be
right at that time.
And I think it's interesting
when you end up with this--
you are trying to run
something globally,
yet the team is so local.
Or the decision-makers
are so local,
but the consequences are global.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: I think I'll
add one more thing to that,
which is it seems like what
Starbucks did-- and we also
saw those with-- do you guys
remember Tay, Microsoft's Tay
bot?
So what happened in
both of these cases--
and I think there's kind of
a common lesson to them--
is they made this product and
they put it out in the world.
And they just kind of
threw it over the wall.
And I mean, I can't believe that
Tay ran for as long as it did.
I mean, to me that's
really surprising.
If you're going to
build an AI or you're
going to build a system that
has all of this feedback in it,
then I think you need
to be watching it much,
much more closely.
And I think that's a
lesson that Starbuck--
they could have had somebody
monitoring it at some level.
And I mean, you guys know how to
build tools to monitor things,
right?
They could have done that
and taken that aspect
of the process more seriously.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: Other questions?
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
related to the failure itself.
So I'm wondering
like, so there's
a book from [INAUDIBLE]
about [INAUDIBLE]..
But my question would be
about, like maybe failure
is good for the system?
Like small-scale failures,
you know, large failures.
So it kind of
strengthens the system.
So in your framework, what
is the scale that failure
is good for the whole system?
How do you measure the scale
of the failure, if it's big
or not?
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think we start
with the premise
that failure is a natural
consequence of building
any system.
And so what we
have focused on is
how you obsess about
failures so that you
learn from them before
they become the big ones.
And also, how you
recognize when your system
is in a fundamentally
different regime.
Because I think that's
another big thing.
Some systems, you can
afford to have failures
in because they're local,
and they're not tragic,
and they don't propagate.
But if you think about like
BP's Deepwater Horizon oil rig.
You know, the consequences
of that failure.
A, it was more likely
to happen because of all
of the factors that obscured
the engineering that they
were doing, right?
It was under the ocean.
It was under the rock.
They couldn't
directly observe it.
They had to use simulations
for a lot of stuff.
And they really relied on
their gut and their intuition
to decide on how to kind of
manage the drilling process.
And what we saw is that,
A, that didn't work.
And B, the consequences
were not only tragic
and that people died,
but were expensive.
I mean, $50 billion.
And long-lasting.
And the environmental
damage is still
something that is present
and being managed.
And so I think our
perspective is that--
it's interesting you
mentioned [INAUDIBLE]
because the black
swan comes up a lot.
And I think there probably are
true black swans out there,
but what we kind of think
is that most of the time,
you can find feathers long
before the black swan happens,
right?
So you can see these
black feathers.
And that the chance
that your system
isn't telling you
any information
that there might be a
problem, that's pretty rare.
What's much more common is
that your organization isn't
learning from that information.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: Yeah.
So in a sense, it's almost
like the issue isn't scale.
So where you have a good
failure or a bad failure
isn't simply scale.
It's sort of what you do
with that failure, right?
So obviously, Deepwater
Horizon is a terrible failure.
It could have still
been a good failure
in a particular sense had
the industry learned from it.
And that's what we
have seen in aviation.
They had some terrible
accidents in the '70s and '80s,
which then triggered
all this learning.
I don't think we are seeing
that in offshore drilling.
And it's really
what you do with it.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah.
And I think even in the
Deepwater Horizon case
in particular, there were
lots of small failures
that preceded that
big failure, right?
There were warning
signs that were ignored,
and so on and so forth.
And I think the dynamics of that
accident are really interesting
and can be really
instructive for thinking
about your question, which is
a really thoughtful question.
Thank you.
CRAIG: Other questions?
I have one.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Great.
CRAIG: I didn't hear two
words very often in your talk.
One, testing.
And the other, redundancy.
And I think [INAUDIBLE].
Would you have a
comment on that?
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah.
Testing is good.
I think part of
why we didn't talk
about it is we know that that's
something that you guys already
do a ton of.
You guys call it the Disaster
Recovery Team, the DRT team.
Is that right?
So I mean, I think
as an organization,
you all take a
fantastic approach.
Actually, it looks a lot
like Jet Propulsion Labs,
where you've kind of
incorporated these outsiders
into how teams are designing
and engineering things.
Yeah.
I mean, testing is
super-important.
If you think about
learning from failures
that you see as
this step, testing
is almost the previous step.
It's like-- sorry.
Setting up situations
where you're
trying to cause
these failures so
you can preemptively
learn from them.
I mean, one of the things
that we do see though,
is that testing isn't
the whole enchilada.
It's not enough because you
can never really reproduce
the real world.
And there's a really
interesting example--
the Facebook IPO.
We go into kind of how
NASDAQ tested for that.
And also, how that
failure still happened.
So testing is awesome.
And I think we kind
of [INAUDIBLE] it
a little bit because we think
that you guys are probably
test evangelists.
Redundancy is
really interesting.
I mean, redundancy
has a huge upside.
But the other thing
redundancy does
is it adds a lot of
complexity to the system.
And so you see kind of
failure after failure
where redundancy is the
cause or exacerbates
the issue in the first place.
And so yes, you need
to have redundancy.
But I think you need to
have redundancy in, as--
I would say, almost like as
redundancy can't be an add-on.
It has to be kind of an
inherent part of the setup.
And if you have
that, it's much more
likely to be an upside
rather than a downside.
ANDRAS TILCSIK:
I'll also say that I
think one problem we see
in a lot of these cases
is that redundancy has these
social and psychological
effects on people.
So one thing we
know is that when
there is some redundancy
in the system,
even if it's not
perfect, people often
tend to believe that it is
perfect or at least very
robust, which then leads
them to take more risks.
So we talked about
Deepwater Horizon just now.
I think that's an
amazing example of that.
There is a point
in that story where
one of the engineers
on board says,
I'm really not happy
with what we are doing.
I'm very reluctant to
go forward with this,
but I know we have
this redundant system.
We have this blowout preventer.
That if everything
else falls apart,
it will just cut things off.
And so he says, I guess that's
what we have that system for,
so let's do it.
And of course, when
the explosion happens
and the failure happens, it
takes out that redundant system
as well.
And I think-- in fact, I'm
pretty convinced that had they
not had that redundant
system, they probably
would not have taken such
a risky series of steps.
CRAIG: Any other questions?
I'm going to take the
moderator's privilege
and ask one more then.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yes.
CRAIG: I read your book.
And one of the things
that was fascinating to me
is the discussion
of bank failures
and the diversity
of the boards there.
I wonder if you could
briefly say something
about that, because
I think that's very
relevant to decision-making
at a place like Google.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Yeah,
this is a fascinating--
totally fascinating study
where these researchers
looked at the failure
of community banks
through the financial crisis.
And what they
found is that banks
that had more bankers
on their board
were actually more
likely to fail,
which is a little surprising.
Because you would
think that bankers
should be pretty good
at managing a bank.
And it turned out it's very
similar to this diversity
result that we saw.
That when the board had
lawyers, or nonprofit people,
or doctors, or
accountants on it,
there was this freeing
up to ask questions.
And to say, hey, I
don't understand this.
Can you all explain this more?
Or like no, we're not going
to go with this new product
because we don't
understand it yet.
It's not like a risk effect.
It's not that the
banks with more bankers
were making more money because
they were taking more risks.
They were making the
same amount of money,
but just failing more.
So they had the same returns.
And I mean, to
your point, I think
that's an example of two things.
And I think I can speak to this
because I sort of straddled
these worlds through my career.
Like normal people think
differently than engineers
some of the time.
And so having a group that
has a mix of backgrounds
can be really powerful to
getting that kind of-- that
questioning and that
diverse perspective.
But also, we should
be thinking about how
to bring outsiders into some of
these most important decisions.
I mean, the example
I think about
is Apple slowed
their iPhone down
with the new operating system.
And that was probably a really
good engineering decision.
It probably made sense.
They could kind of make the
performance more predictable.
The phones didn't turn off.
But that's not how the
public viewed that.
And I think if Apple had pulled
in somebody off the street--
well, that's hard in
this area because there's
so many engineers.
But pulled in a non-engineer,
they might have said,
this is crazy.
This is not a good solution.
And so I think that
there's an element of that.
And it's interesting that
surface-level diversity
and the kind of
professional diversity
have such a similar
and striking impact.
CRAIG: We have time
for more questions.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: We'll
also be up here for a minute
if anybody has anything
they want to chat about.
CRAIG: All right.
Well, let's thank our speakers.
And I encourage you
to read the book.
It is fascinating.
Thank you again.
ANDRAS TILCSIK: Thank you.
CHRIS CLEARFIELD: Thank
you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]